This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This sound is unmistakable. Maybe you find it kind of lulling like I do since it signifies the end of a trip to the grocery store. You've found all the things on your list and now you get to just stand there and zone out for a second or flip through a passive magazine while the checkout person does the work. That's our new producer, Katie Mangle. I myself find that sound a bit anxiety inducing since it's also the sound of the total that I'm going to have to pay, going up and up and up and up.
这里是99%隐形节目。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这个声音让人无法忽视。也许你和我一样，觉得它有种安抚人心的效果，因为它标志着一次超市购物之旅的结束。你找到了购物清单上的所有物品，现在你只需站在那里发呆一秒钟，或者随手翻翻杂志，而收银员则在完成剩下的工作。那是我们的新制作人凯蒂·曼格。我自己却觉得这个声音有点让人焦虑，因为它也是我需要支付的总金额不断往上涨的声音。
When I go to the grocery store and check out, I'm utterly amazed at how well the skaters can read barcodes. No, I don't tell the checkout people, my wife always did. My husband here is the one that invented that barcode, and they just kind of look at just as if to say, yeah, I believe that. Of course, today, they would look at you as if to say, you mean there was a time they didn't have a barcode? It's hard to imagine now, a world without barcodes, a world without George Laura.
当我大包小包地去超市结账时，我总是惊叹于收银员扫描条形码的速度是如此之快。不，我并没有对收银员说这些，我妻子总是这么说。“我丈夫可是发明了那个条形码的人。”而他们只是看了看，仿佛在说：“是吗，我相信。”当然，现在的他们看你的眼神大概会像在说：“你是说曾经还有没有条形码的年代？”现在很难想象一个没有条形码的世界，一个没有乔治·劳勒的世界。
Well, hello. I'm George J. Laura. I'm the one that invented the UPC bar, and symbol in 1973. Now, some of you might be saying to yourselves, I thought Joseph Woodland invented the barcode. And if you're saying that to yourself, you are a nerd, and I love you for it. And just hold your nerd horses because we're getting
大家好。我是乔治·J·劳勒。我就是那个在1973年发明UPC条形码符号的人。现在，你们有些人可能会对自己说：“我以为约瑟夫·伍德兰发明了条形码呢。”如果你这么想，那你绝对是个极客，我为你感到骄傲。不过请按捺住你们作为极客的好奇心，因为我们马上就要
to Woodland right now. It started the way a lot of things start with people trying to make more money. The grocery business decided that they needed some way to reduce their overhead. One of the main places they felt they were losing money was the checkout line. They came up with the idea of having some kind of a scannable code. Which would move people more quickly through the line. One of the first people that started working on it was an engineer named Joseph Woodland. After working on the Manhattan Project, Woodland moved on to develop an innovative way to produce
讲到伍德兰了。这一切的开始和许多事情一样，都是源于人们想要赚更多的钱。杂货业决定他们需要某种方法来降低运营成本。他们觉得最浪费钱的地方之一就是收银台。于是他们想出了某种可扫描代码的主意，这可以让顾客更快地通过收银台。最早开始研究这个问题的人之一是一位名叫约瑟夫·伍德兰的工程师。在参与曼哈顿计划后，伍德兰转而开发一种创新方式来制作
elevator music. He was jamming on this project probably set to make a whole bunch of money until, and this is according to Woodland's New York Times obituary, his father forbid him from getting into the industry because it was controlled by the mob. So Woodland moved on from elevator music to barcodes. He was trying to come up with a symbol that when scanned would translate to a series of numbers that a computer could use to identify a product. So one day he's sitting on the beach in Miami, Florida. So the legend goes.
背景音乐。他当时正全力投入这个项目，本打算赚一大笔钱，直到——根据伍德兰在《纽约时报》上的讣告——他的父亲禁止他进入这个行业，因为那里被黑手党把持。于是伍德兰从背景音乐转向了条形码。他试图设计一种符号，扫描时可以转化为计算机用来识别产品的数字序列。所以有一天，传说他正坐在佛罗里达州迈阿密的沙滩上。
And Woodland's thinking about his days and the boy scouts and Morse code. As one tends to do on the beach. And he's kind of absent-mindedly drawing in the sand with his fingers. When suddenly he looks down and he's got it. He's dragged his four fingers through the sand in the shape of concentric circles. Instead of dot dot dot dash dash dash he thinks I can use skinny and wide lines. Bullseye. Bullseye.
伍德兰想起了他当童子军时的日子以及摩斯密码，人们在海滩上往往会浮想联翩。他一边走神，一边用手指在沙滩上随手画着。突然，他低头一看，他成功了。他在沙子上用四根手指划出了同心圆的形状。与其用点点点划划划，他想，我可以利用细线和粗线。靶心。靶心。
The very first barcodes were in the shape of a bullseye. Actually, they didn't call them barcodes yet. Woodland's invention was called a classifying apparatus and method. I'm really glad that we don't call them that anymore. That was 1948, and then for about 20 years, the bullseye idea gathered dust. The scanners and other equipment needed to put the system in place were just too expensive for any of it to be feasible. Fast forward to 1973. The technology is now a bit more affordable and a group of
最早的条形码就是靶心形状的。实际上，他们当时还不叫它们条形码。伍德兰的发明被称为“分类装置和方法”。我真庆幸我们现在不这么叫它们了。那是1948年，随后的大约20年里，靶心这个创意一直被束之高阁。当时实施该系统所需的扫描仪和其他设备实在太昂贵了，根本不可行。快进到1973年。这项技术现在变得更加亲民了，以一个叫阿兰·哈伯曼的人为首的一群
supermarket executives led by a guy named Alan Haberman are like, okay, barcode or bust, we're doing this. By that time there were a few other designs out there, but none were perfect. So they put together a list of qualities that their ideal barcode would have and asked 14 different companies to come up with a proposal. It could be no larger than one and a half square inches. How to have a good enough depth of field that could read about a foot and a half above the scanner. How to be omnidirectional. That's George Laura again. He was working at IBM at the time, which was one of the companies competing to make the best barcode. And most people thought that a circular design like Woodlands would probably work best because of the way the scanners worked.
超市高管们表示：“好吧，要么搞定条形码，要么拉倒，我们干了。”当时市面上还有其他一些设计，但都不完美。于是他们列出了理想条形码所需具备的特质，并邀请了14家不同的公司提交方案。它的面积不能超过1.5平方英寸。需要有足够好的景深，能在扫描仪上方约一.五英尺的地方进行读取。需要具备全方位扫描能力。又是乔治·劳勒的声音。他当时在IBM工作，IBM正是参与竞争制作最佳条形码的公司之一。大多数人认为，像伍德兰那样的圆形设计可能会效果最好，因为当时扫描仪的工作原理就是如此。
And those days, just about every scanner was a single line. And you can just picture that if you had a single line and it was going in the direction of the bar, it would not read all the bars. Woodlands' original circular design solved And you can just picture that if you had a single line and it was going in the direction of the bar, it would not read all the bars. Woodland's original circular design solved this because it could be read from any direction. That meant the checkout person didn't have to take your bag of cheetos and turn it in just the right way before it could pass over the scanner.
在那些日子里，几乎每台扫描仪都是单线扫描。你可以想象一下，如果你有一条单线，它沿着条纹的方向扫过去，它就无法读取所有的条纹。伍德兰最初的圆形设计解决了这一问题，因为它可以从任何方向被读取。这意味着收银员不需要把你的奇多薯片拿起来，转到刚好合适的角度才能通过扫描仪。
But George didn't think the bulls-eye symbol would work. I couldn't support that as the solution to what the grocery industry wanted. Because to me, there was no way that it would fulfill their specifications. My integrity just would not let me come up with a bunch of bull. So George went back to the drawing table. My wife said I came back and I would work on it day and night. Come back at night and again most of us was thinking arithmetic, trying to prove that this would work. Also I have to admit I I had a disprove that some of the others wouldn't work. He ultimately came up with a rectangular barcode that fit more code into less space, which was crucial since grocery manufacturers were already grumbling about having to make room
但乔治认为靶心符号行不通。“我无法支持那个作为杂货业想要解决问题的方案。因为在我看来，它根本不可能满足他们的规格要求。我的正直不容许我搞出一堆废话。”于是乔治重新回到设计桌前。“我妻子说我回来后日夜都在钻研。晚上回来，而且大多数时候我们都在做算术，试图证明这行得通。同时我必须承认，我得证明其他人的方案行不通。”他最终设计出了一个矩形条形码，在更小的空间里容纳了更多代码，这至关重要，因为杂货制造商已经在抱怨必须腾出空间
for this new symbol on their packaging. But there was still the issue of the one-line scanner. Somehow, we got the idea that if we used an X for the scan pattern, which could be developed very easily with a pair of mirrors, then the barcode could be read by the scanner in a matter of which way it was oriented as it passed. So even though Woodland came up with the original idea of using lines of various widths. George Lourer did more than just change that shape from a circle to a rectangle. He improved on the symbol, the code behind the symbol, and the scanners that read the symbol. Even Joe Woodland thought so.
来印制这个新符号。但单线扫描仪的问题依然存在。不知怎么的，我们萌生了一个想法：如果我们用X形作为扫描图案，这可以通过一对镜子非常容易地实现，那么无论条形码在通过时方向如何，扫描仪都能读取它。因此，尽管伍德兰最早提出了使用各种宽度线条的想法，但乔治·劳勒做的事情远不止是将形状从圆形改成矩形。他对符号本身、符号背后的代码以及读取符号的扫描仪都进行了改进。就连乔·伍德兰也这么认为。
Joe Woodland was very enthusiastic. He worked with me. In fact, he wrote the actual proposal for the submission to the grocery industry, but it was my invention of the particular symbol and barcode that we see today. The Symbol Selection Committee unanimously voted for George Luror's rectangular symbol and code. They called it the Universal Product Code, or UPC, and a year later, in 1974, a pack of Riggley's chewing gum became the first item to ever be scanned with the UPC bar code. If barcodes hadn't been invented, the entire layout and architecture of commerce would have been different. The impacts are very difficult to overestimate.
“乔·伍德兰非常热情。他和我一起合作。事实上，他为提交给杂货业的提案撰写了实际内容，但我们今天看到的特定符号和条形码是我的发明。”符号评选委员会一致投票赞成了乔治·劳勒的矩形符号和代码。他们将其命名为通用产品代码，即UPC。一年后的1974年，一包箭牌口香糖成为了历史上第一个被UPC条形码扫描的商品。如果条形码没有被发明出来，商业的整个布局和架构将会完全不同。其影响之深远，怎么估计都不为过。
My name is Sanjay Sarma. I'm a professor of mechanical engineering at MIT. Sanjay Sarma has also worked with an organization called GS1. That stands for Global Standards 1. And if you need a barcode on your product, you have to go through GS1 to get it. Imagine if Telfer numbers were standardized, right? And you didn't have any codes and two people could have the same phone number, you know, you need standards.
我叫桑杰·萨尔马。我是麻省理工学院机械工程教授。桑杰·萨尔马还曾与一个名为GS1的组织合作。那代表全球标准1。如果你的产品上需要一个条形码，你就必须通过GS1来获取。想象一下，如果电话号码没有标准化，对吧？如果你没有任何代码，两个人可能会拥有相同的电话号码，你知道，你需要标准。
When barcodes became the standard, they didn't just make check out lines faster. They allowed stores to keep track of huge amounts of inventory and to collect data on what we were buying. Data they could use to keep us coming back for more without barcodes. As super stores might not exist, but equally, you know, a small store might need more employees to run it. It's like the grease that makes the machine run. That's one of the key elements of efficiency in our capitalist system.
当条形码成为标准时，它们不仅使结账队伍变得更快。它们还允许商店跟踪巨量的库存，并收集关于我们购买行为的数据。这些数据可用于吸引我们不断回购。如果没有条形码，超级市场可能就不会存在；但同样地，一家小商店可能需要更多员工来运营。它就像是让机器运转的润滑油。这是我们资本主义体系中效率的关键要素之一。
And when you put it like that, you can see why for some people, the barcode has come to represent everything they hate about capitalism and consumerism. You can get rap candies of every kind. Bubble gum, lollipops, fun-sized candy bars, just $1.89. When I was a punk kid, if a band's album had a barcode on it, we knew they were a complete sell-outs. It ain't the barcode's fault, but it's become the symbol or the glyph of technology where afraid of or don't understand or being a cog in a wheel in a larger monolithic machine, the matrix, if you will.
当你这样说的时候，你就会明白为什么对某些人来说，条形码已经成为他们痛恨资本主义和消费主义的一切象征。各种说唱糖果。泡泡糖、棒棒糖、迷你糖果条，只要1.89美元。当我还是个朋克青年时，如果一支乐队的专辑上印有条形码，我们就知道他们彻底商业化、出卖灵魂了。这不是条形码的错，但它已经变成了我们所恐惧或不理解的技术的符号或象形文字，或者说是庞大垄断机器中的一个齿轮，如果你愿意的话，这就是母体。
Oh, I will, Jerry Whiting. My name is Jerry Whiting. I am the founder of Azealia Software here in Seattle, Washington. I've been writing software that prints spark codes for 25 years now. They aren't bad, they aren't good, they're just tools, but most people look at them and don't even know where to start. So let's demystify for a minute and look at what's inside the barcode.
哦，我愿意，杰里·怀丁。我叫杰里·怀丁。我是华盛顿州西雅图市阿泽利亚软件公司的创始人。我编写打印条形码的软件已经有25年了。它们不坏，也不好，它们只是工具，但大多数人看着它们甚至不知从何入手。所以让我们花一分钟时间揭开它的神秘面纱，看看条形码里面到底有什么。
Again, what we're talking about here is the UPC barcode that George Lourer invented. This is the barcode that you and I and everyone in the world has had the most interaction with. The UPC barcode is divided into two halves. It's actually two barcodes sitting right next to each other. You can see this visually because there are these longer bars that come down in the middle and on each side. Those are called the guard bars. The guard bars tell the scanner that the code is starting and ending. The left half of the barcode tells you who the manufacturer is, and the right half tells you which particular product it is. And this was something I didn't realize.
再次强调，我们在这里讨论的是乔治·劳勒发明的UPC条形码。这是你、我和世界上每个人接触最多的条形码。UPC条形码分为两半。它实际上是紧挨着彼此的两个条形码。你可以从视觉上看出这一点，因为在中间和两侧有一些向下延伸的更长的条。这些被称为警戒条。警戒条告诉扫描仪代码从哪里开始，到哪里结束。条形码的左半部分告诉你制造商是谁，右半部分告诉你具体是什么产品。这是我以前没有意识到的一点。
The scanner is reading both the white and the dark lines. To understand the scanner, just consider yourself in a dark room where the wall behind you has bars painted on it. And you took a flashlight and shined it over your head across the bars. You would see the room get a little lighter when you were over the white bars and it would get dark when it was over the dark bars. Black lines that don't reflect the laser light back to the scanner register as a one. white lines equal zero. There are actually 95 evenly spaced columns on a UPC barcode. A thick black line is actually a bunch of ones right next to each other.
扫描仪同时在读取白色线条和黑色线条。为了理解扫描仪的工作原理，你可以把自己想象在一个黑暗的房间里，你身后的墙上画着条纹。你拿着手电筒，举过头顶从条纹上方照过去。当手电筒照在白色条纹上方时，你会看到房间变亮了一点，而在黑暗条纹上方时则会变暗。不反射激光回到扫描仪的黑色线条被记录为1，白色线条等于0。UPC条形码上实际上有95个均匀间隔的列。粗黑线实际上是一连串紧挨在一起的1。
The computer adds all that together and you get a string of 12 numbers. This number goes to the computer. The computer now looks up in its table to get the information, such as what is the product, how much they're charging for it, but that is not in the barcode. The only thing that's in the barcode is where the computer should look. This number is also printed below the barcode just in case the scanner isn't working, which for me really makes the whole mystery a little anti-climactic. I mean, it's right there. So when most people until recently thought of barcodes they thought of something that was a combination of bars and stripes. More recently two
计算机将所有这些加在一起，你就会得到一串12位数字。这个数字会发送给计算机。计算机现在会在其表格中查找信息，例如这是什么产品，他们收取多少费用，但这些信息并不在条形码中。条形码里唯一的内容就是计算机应该去哪里查找。这个数字也印在条形码下方，以防扫描仪无法工作，对我而言，这确实让整个神秘感变得有点虎头蛇尾。我的意思是，它就写在那里。因此，直到最近，当大多数人想到条形码时，他们想到的都是条纹和线条的组合。最近，
dimensional barcodes which are they look like crossword puzzles have emerged the most popular being QR bar codes, quick response, that are scanned by cell phones. We've all seen these, and maybe a few of us have actually bothered to pull out our cell phones and download the app required to scan them. Yeah, there's something about them that I find kind of lame or annoying. You know, it's like no, Chili's. I don't want more info on the Blooming Onion.
二维条形码——它们看起来像纵横字谜——已经涌现出来，其中最流行的是通过手机扫描的QR条形码，即快速响应码。我们都见过这些，也许我们当中有几个人真的费心掏出手机下载了扫描所需的应用程序。是的，它们身上有一种东西让我觉得有点逊或者烦人。你知道，这就好像，不，智利餐厅，我不需要关于洋葱花球的更多信息。
Well, if you did, you might know that the Blooming Onion is from Outback. So anyway, I googled why are QR codes lame? And I got a bunch of articles basically saying they're actually really useful. They're just being misused. Mostly by advertisers, we've just started slapping them on every single thing. But Jerry Whiting, he still believes in them. The nice thing about QR barcodes is they are not just a lookup number to an external database. Yes, it can be a chunk of text.
好吧，如果你知道了，你可能会知道洋葱花球来自澳拜客牛排馆。所以不管怎样，我谷歌搜索了“为什么QR码很逊？”我得到了一堆文章，基本上说它们其实非常有用。只是被滥用了。主要是被广告商滥用，我们开始把它们胡乱贴在每一个东西上。但杰里·怀丁，他仍然对它们深信不疑。QR条形码的好处在于它们不仅仅是一个连接到外部数据库的查询编号。是的，它可以是一段文本。
It can be a URL. It can be a whole lot of different things. But there is no central authority that tells you what or how to do anything. Meaning you don't have to go through GS1 to get a QR code, which lets people do stuff like make a giant picture of Amy Goodman's face entirely out of QR codes. This is my QR code, Amy Goodman Portrait, made with 2,304 unique QR codes that link to nine years of democracy now videos.
它可以是一个网址。它可以是很多不同的东西。但没有任何一个中央机构告诉你应该做什么或怎么做。这意味着你不需要通过GS1来获取QR码，这让人们能够做出诸如用纯QR码拼出一张巨大的艾米·古德曼面孔之类的事情。“这是我的QR码艾米·古德曼肖像，由2304个独特的QR码组成，链接到长达九年的‘现在民主’视频。”
Besides the QR code, Laura and Woodland's original barcodes have spawned a bunch of other barcodes. They're used for all sorts of things. There's code 128, which is mostly used for packaging and shipping. There's PostNet, which is used by the Post Office to sort mail. There are barcodes that use radio frequencies to send out data. They're called RFID tags, and they aren't really barcodes at all. They just get put in the same category because like barcodes, they're being used to keep track of inventory. With a grocery cart full of RFID tagged items, one could conceivably wheel their cart through
除了QR码，劳勒和伍德兰最初的条形码还催生了一系列其他条形码。它们被用于各种各样的事情。例如Code 128，主要用于包装和运输。还有PostNet，被邮局用于分拣邮件。还有使用射频发送数据的条形码。它们被称为RFID标签，它们根本不是真正的条形码。它们只是被归入同一类别，因为它们和条形码一样，被用于追踪库存。推着一车装有RFID标签商品的购物车，人们完全可以把购物车推过
a big hoop that would read all the contents all at once, basically eliminating the checkout line entirely and allowing more people to pass through stores even more quickly so that we can all buy more stuff. Barcoads help us keep track of prescriptions, library books, luggage, endangered animals. There are so many barcodes on so many things that according to Jerry Whiting, when future archeologists come across remnants of our backward-ass civilization
一个大环，就能一次性读取所有内容，这基本上完全省去了结账队伍，让更多人能够更快地通过商店，以便我们所有人都能买更多东西。条形码帮助我们追踪处方药、图书馆书籍、行李、濒危动物。有那么多的条形码贴在那么多东西上，以至于根据杰里·怀丁的说法，当未来的考古学家偶然发现我们这个落后文明的残余时
and they stumble across a barcode, they're going to sign it religious significance if they don't understand the supply chain. We had no idea how far it was going to go. We thought it would stay just within the grocery industry. But of course, it didn't just stay in the grocery industry. It actually went way beyond that, all the way, to conspiracy. There is in fact a silly conspiracy theory that all barcodes have the number of the beast 6666 encoded into them. Yeah, it has to do with those guard bars that come
如果他们不理解供应链，他们偶然发现一个条形码时，就会赋予它宗教意义。我们完全不知道它会发展到多远。我们以为它只会停留在杂货行业内部。但当然，它并没有仅仅停留在杂货行业。它实际上远远超越了这一点，一直延伸到了阴谋论。事实上有一个荒谬的阴谋论，认为所有条形码里都编码了野兽数字666。是的，这与那些出现在
at the beginning, middle, and end of every bar code. And it's basically true that there are three sixes coded into the guard bars. The answer to why is a bit technical. You can read about it on George Laura's personal website in the FAQ section, if you want. But as Exhibit B, I submit George himself. Well, hello. I'm George J. Laura. After we were done with our interview, he was talking a little bit more about his job at IBM.
每个条形码开头、中间和结尾的警戒条有关。警戒条中确实编码了三个6，这基本是真的。至于为什么，原因有点技术性。如果你想了解，可以在乔治·劳勒个人网站的常见问题解答部分阅读相关内容。但作为证据B，我请出乔治本人。“大家好。我是乔治·J·劳勒。”在我们采访结束后，他更多地谈到了他在IBM的工作。
And then when I'd come home at night, I'd go, oh, I had a tough day. Well, my poor wife would stay and care for kids. And then he started talking about his wife and his kids. She had the hard job, believe it, she gave up her career, which was a teaching career in order to take care of the kids. And believe me, we are so proud of those kids. Really, they are, you just couldn't answer for better kids.
“然后当我晚上回家时，我会说，哦，我今天过得很艰难。而我可怜的妻子则要留下来照顾孩子。”接着他开始谈论他的妻子和孩子。“她承担了艰巨的工作，相信我，她放弃了自己的职业——那是一份教师职业——为了照顾孩子们。并且相信我，我们为这些孩子们感到无比自豪。真的，他们就是，你简直找不到更好的孩子了。”
And this is because my wife spent her career raising those kids. I'm just so lucky. So I don't know. Does that sound like a Satan worshiper to you guys? My daughter has a bachelor's degree. 99% invisible was produced this week by Kaby Mingle with Sam Greenspan, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Wars. Special thanks to Jenny Morgan for production help. We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio KALW in San Francisco and produced of the offices of Arksign, an architecture firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Our younger son has a PhD from state.
“这是因为我妻子把她的职业生涯都花在了抚养这些孩子上。我真是太幸运了。”所以，我不知道。这听起来像是一个崇拜撒旦的人吗？我女儿拥有学士学位。“99%隐形”本周由凯蒂·曼格制作，合作者包括萨姆·格林斯潘、埃弗里·特鲁夫曼以及我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢珍妮·摩根对制作提供的帮助。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播KALW的项目，制作地点位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心的一家建筑事务所Arksign。我们的小儿子拥有州立大学的博士学位。
You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. We all tweet. You can find us. We have a Tumblr. It's fantastic. But if you want to link to George Luror's self-published autobiography called Engineering was fun. Explomation point. Go to 99pi.org.
你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。我们都会发推特。你可以找到我们。我们有一个Tumblr。它棒极了。但如果你想链接到乔治·劳勒自费出版的名为《工程学很有趣》（带叹号）的自传，请访问99pi.org。
Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX的广播台。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。